good evening everyone it's a it's a
pleasure and it's an honor to be here at
Hillsdale College it's been about a
decade since I was here I'm very
grateful to Larry Arne for for inviting
me I just had a wonderful experience at
the dinner time at the dinner table
being able to talk to some of the
excellent Hillsdale students it's it's a
honor to be here but it's also i have to
admit it's going to be quite a challenge
for me i'm here because i'm basically
promoting a book that's just been
published Rebecca mentioned it it's
called rebound getting America back to
grade I think there may be a possibility
of some of the books being sold at the
end came out about two weeks ago and
I've been promoting it and that's one of
the reasons why I'm here but I'm talking
about American greatness what made
America great how we get America back to
grade butts challenge for me because
it's not only the students here but the
faculty of Hillsdale that have some of
the best scholars in the world that
Chronicle American greatness in American
exceptionalism i hope i have something
to add but frankly before this audience
i'm aware of my limitations and i know
that i'm just following in the footsteps
of many of the professors and scholars
that have worked in Hillsdale and
elsewhere because when you come right
down to it even though this book is part
history parked policy I'm a foreign
policy expert as you mentioned Rebecca
for 22 years I led the foreign policy
department at heritage and I was indeed
an assistant secretary of state so
that's mainly where my expertise is but
before that I was a historian I have two
advanced degrees in history from
Georgetown and one of those is in
intellectual history and I did my
master's thesis was on Friedrich
Nietzsche and Sigmund Freud
so I have an interesting ideas
especially and how they are promulgated
in culture particularly popular culture
and so that's it was my interest in
history that sparked the question for
sparked me to write this book and
sparked the question of me asking again
what made America a great nation what
were its ingredients what were the key
ID ideas and the values that made
America different from other countries
well on some level this is well-trodden
ground it's there's a veritable cottage
industry of books and academic studies
on the subject of American
exceptionalism but I wanted to take
another look at the question from a
different angle but not only from the
perspective of intellectual history the
history of ideas but also consciously to
deduce from the analysis some concrete
guideposts for a way forward my thought
was that if I could distill the
ingredients of what have made America a
successful nation to boil them down to
their essentials to essentially discover
the historical DNA of America that could
possibly give me some guideposts on the
way out of the current crises that we
find ourselves in I also wanted to find
frankly a counter-narrative to the
dominant one that exists today that no
matter how big or how small a problem is
it must be sold by government and that's
because as that narrative goes it's
always been that way it's been that way
since the New Deal it's been that way
since the 1960s you know it's been along
for almost a century so get over it you
know that's the way it is I believe that
that narrative is not only not true but
also misses the point of how we got to
the point in our history where we became
the greatest nation on earth and that
we've been living off essentially a
false pretense of what made is great and
that we're losing that DNA losing that
understanding is going to possibly lead
us into a terminable root of decline and
this is what worried me and this is why
I decided to write the book so let me
begin
let me ask the question what made
America great what made it successful
it's been explained many times but the
answer is complex and and I for the
interests of the talk here I don't want
to go off on to any details but I would
boil it down and sum it up this way it
was a fierce sense of personal
responsibility and also moral restraint
enabling not only our system of limited
government and our love of freedom but
also our free market system to flourish
these three things the American ethos
the limited government and economic
freedom interacted in a unique and
successful way not seeing anywhere in
human history for much of this history
our Civic culture was based on the
belief that individual responsibility
and also moral restraint were necessary
preconditions for our freedom they
provided a social order that may
political freedom possible they also
tamed the wild horses of the free
economy and it which gave the
intrapreneurial spirit a social purpose
and turning what otherwise it could have
been a selfish individualism into a
cause for the greater good well their
yarn often explains this I've talked to
him about it many times these values and
these systems rested on certain ideas
and they will be familiar to many of you
here at Hillsdale who study politics and
the Constitution design it was number
one the idea of natural rights number
two the premise that freedom is
fundamentally a political idea as to how
those rides experienced through the
individual should be protected by the
government and number three the
assumption that the greatest potential
source of tyranny was not some other
class not some company not some group of
people in civil society but the power of
government those were the ideas the
premises and the assumptions
of American greatness the question is
and I discuss in the book is how do we
get off track how do we lose our way
from these values and this vision well
the answer normally starts of course
with a progressive movement and I think
that's correct much of the attack on the
tradition of constitutionally limited
government comes from that movement and
the story of how that happened is well
documented and it's well understood and
swell explained but frankly there's more
to it than that there were changes in
our culture which have sources of
inspiration besides American
progressivism and there were detours and
there were external factors but which
make it difficult to draw straight lines
in intellectual history from that era to
the current one something explain what I
mean by that what I do in the book is
identified three key developments that
happened largely in the late 50s and the
1960s which fundamentally changed our
civic culture and our social culture
roughly at the same time in other words
our value systems about how we see
ourselves as moral human beings changed
at the same time that our expectations
of government changed it was the
interaction over a period of 50 years
between the Civic and the social culture
that has given us the dominant culture
that we live with today so there's three
of them now the first of these changes
that happen at that time we're well
known that it's a rise in the expansion
of the entitlement in the welfare states
by the Great Society programs this set
us on the path of government dependency
that is so prevalent today it's crucial
not so much because in the way I'm
looking at this not so much because it
created dependency among lower-income
people in terms of what we call the
welfare state i think more important to
the changes in the culture was how it
changed the political and social
expectations of the middle class with
the onset of Social Security Medicare
the farm bill in other words the
expansion of programs into the middle
class we moved into the Social
Democratic model from Europe where there
was an expectation that there was a
universal participe
of all classes in the state benefit
system in some way or another okay
that's fairly well known the second is
development is a little less well known
at least it's less talked about maybe
well known but it's not talked about as
much in this context and that was the
rise of the counterculture of the 60s
the counterculture overturned the
traditional culture of personal and
individual responsibility and steady
replaced it with a new focus on freedom
that was seen as personal liberation
from the constraints of morality and
religion the baby boomers I'm one of
them became the me generation the 70s
became the the media the me decade
became there was a famous book written
by Christopher lash in the nineteen
seventy may remit mentioned and remember
this is called the age of narcissism
interest in the enough flash was a man
of the left and he was making this as a
cultural critique of consumer capitalism
but it could just as easily apply to the
counter culture that existed at the time
it was a time where I'm okay you're okay
you're perfect enough you don't have to
change I won't judge you don't judge me
that was pretty much the popular
cultural norm many of the old rugged
virtues that existed prior to this time
without the door instead of sucking it
up and working hard to take care of
ourselves and our family as our first
order of business it became about our
precious self expression they voting
conformity and an almost narcissistic
focus on our inner life and our
psychological needs in other words the
counterculture changed the moral culture
how one define one's happiness and about
and also what our ultimate obligations
were its model was and probably still is
love yourself first and then from that
all other love and everything else will
come let's start with yourself first now
over time obviously my generation the
baby boomers attenuated the excesses of
the 60s even Steve Jobs who spent some
time you know on a Apple
it was in Oregon and with the India for
six months you know he finally cut his
hair and started bathing but he
revolutionized the entire IT industry
and so these are the dominant figures in
our culture business and otherwise they
became you may remember David Brooks's
book Bobo's and paradise they called in
the boat the bohemian bourgeoisie they
got rid of the excesses of the 60s but
they kept the core values of that era
especially its focus on personal
fulfillment instead of personal
obligation and they also march through
the institution's they became the
dominant force in America's ruling
elites they certainly are the dominant
force of Americans universities this one
accepted now the third development so I
got the first one the Great Society the
second was a counterculture the third
that developed in this timeframe was the
political intellectual movement it was
the new left's transformation of
American liberalism it was the
transformation of progressivism instead
it moved beyond what happened in the 60s
with the rise of the new left it moved
beyond the previous focus that
progressives had had on expanding
government programs mainly protect poor
people to protect you know children in
the factories it had a used to have a
highly social economic side to it but
what happened with the new left in the
50 60 s began to focus more cultural
issues themes of personal mainly sexual
liberation took over from you know
economic liberation it was making a
cultural critique of capitalism is
something that supposedly oppresses once
personhood and inner freedom anybody who
studied the new left knows where all
these ideas came from they came from
Antonio Gramsci who talked about
cultural hegemony he was a Italian
ennis and there were marxists Norman
brown dill Hemric herbivore kooza who
brought freud into the cultural critique
of capitalism so we had changed
dramatically from the old 19th century
proletariat model to something different
and all these movements of the new left
gave rise to many of the movements in a
modern American liberalism we all
recognize them today it's gender and
sexual politics multiculturalism
diversity identity politics all of these
movements came out of the confluence of
the counterculture and the new left from
the 60s so the change here at this time
was to update the old socialist war on
capitalism and individual freedom but
the war or capitalism and individual
freedom remains that still the core
principle is just updated in a different
way it turned away from the 19th century
preoccupations and focuses instead on a
Cultural Revolution so what this did and
the reason why I'm spending time on it
is this change both the moral and the
Civic culture of the United States it
not only gave liberation a new narrative
freeing oneself from political and
capitalist oppression could conveniently
be expressed by any number of things
overturning sexual restraints and the
like so suddenly once personal happiness
of what one did and was personal life
suddenly took on a greater political
meaning or at least you could excuse it
to the point where all you were really
doing was perhaps expression your inner
need to be free from the constraints of
society sounded plausible now I'd like
to add a word of caution here for most
of the early civil rights movement it
was a traditional American idea of
freedom that was a play it was not this
new left one focused on group rights and
identity politics throughout most of the
50s and the early 60s the central idea
have been to give blacks the rice they
deserved as individuals but have been
denied by a slavery d segregation and
racism
that's the way had been seen by
Frederick Douglass but also even by
Martin Luther King jr. it was understood
as fulfilling the original promise and
dream of the Declaration of Independence
and therefore the American family
notwithstanding to the three fixed
Clause of the Constitution and the
compromises that had been made to put
the Union together the i'm making this
point because it was the original ideas
of the american founding that inspired
king and the other civil rights movement
it was not the new left it was not
antonio gramsci it was not Herbert Mark
who'sa and this is even to the extent
that you can say the progressives of the
19th century were critical of the
American Founding and constitutionalism
they never went as far as these new left
cultural critics did who was actually
going beyond the notion of
constitutional government and going into
the very notion of personal morality the
reason why I'm emphasizing this is
because the the focus of Rights of today
of minorities as group rights as group
identity rights and not as individual
rights it comes from this the influence
today does come from the new left so
it's a distinction from the original
civil rights movement and it how to prep
a profound effect in my opinion it
creates and I think it causes a huge
confusion in this country over what
civil rights really is we talk sometimes
about the confusion about natural
difference between natural rights and
political rights there's also a
confusion between the the individual
rights as understood by the founders and
the group rights is understood by the
new left that accounts for the
schizophrenic inability of some
Americans to draw a distinction between
the right of an individual as an
individual no matter what their race is
no matter what their gender is that they
have an innate human value regardless of
what gender or group there from that
gives them the value not only in the
sense of being recognized by God or by
nature or even by society as opposed to
their individuality being defined
as a member of a certain group brass
persecuted in history or by society but
that gives them a sort of a special
sense of needing protection from the
government that difference there comes
from this influence that happened during
these decades now all three of these
things in my opinion created a toxic
combination the key is is that all these
developments counterculture that he left
and also the expansion of the of the
government happened roughly at the same
time they undermine the traditional
American ethos of personal
responsibility but the overall effect
the overall effect and the reason why
I'm talking about it in the context of
politics is that we lost the moral the
intellectual and the political breaks
that had once placed that Americans had
once placed on the expansion of
government it was now not only okay to
be dependent upon government because she
got a benefit from it it was part of the
social contract I paid into Social
Security I deserved to get something out
of it that kind of pragmatic explanation
but with these other factors put into it
it was also seen as a positive and
perhaps even morally necessary thing to
do and to expect from your government my
father was from the generator from the
depression generation and he told me the
story that when his mother my
grandmother died in nineteen sixty he
discovered that she had a debt of eight
hundred dollars from when she had a
grocery store during the Depression when
she was carrying the debt or the the sum
of our neighborhoods neighbors were not
able to pay for their grocery bills so
she carried the debt for them because I
just couldn't afford it but she couldn't
afford it either so my father discovered
it he went out and he was just a young
father I was only about eight years old
and he had took a loan and he paid off
his mother's debt and he went out and he
tracked down the retailer grocer and he
gave him the money saying here my
mother's dead is now paid why would he
do that me today they're probably some
Americans who would do that but they're
a lot who would say it wasn't my fault
you know you know she was it wasn't my
debt but he had a sense that he had to
honor his mother there was a sense of
shame of having that debt that that is
what has not only been lost about the
sense of debt but also the sense that we
have no qualms about expecting to get
some from the government that we didn't
necessarily put anything in ourselves
that ethos has gone largely in a large
part of the country and now it's kind of
like it's my do it's what I what I
expect and when I'm saying we and you
are not necessarily talking about people
in this audience I'm talking about the
country the country at large and not all
not even all of those think this but
that certainly has been a change the
results have not been pretty charles
Murray for example documents the
corrosive impact of the cultural change
of these values on lower-income people
in his book coming apart if you've not
read it I urge you to go out and get it
you know anybody ever heard of this book
coming to part charles Murray yeah you
go out and get it because he's a
sociologist and economist and he go he
goes back and he compares communities
from today to where they were in the 60s
and and almost to every single one of
them the crimes up the drugs uses up the
marriage is down there's a lot of social
dysfunction and he attributes a lot of
this to the decline in the virtues of
marriage industriousness integrity
honesty which existed by the way in the
same income level of the same class of
people back in the 60s so it's not about
class it's not that these are just poor
people and therefore you which is a kind
of an odd thing for a liberal to say is
were there are poor people you were
expecting to have any values right he
wasn't being that kind of conscious city
he says they did have them but they
don't have them now and they don't have
the social political capital they once
had to climb up the ladder of social
ladder and go and climb up the social
ladder of mobility that they have or
used to have that has funded fun
we changed so what had happened in my
estimation because of these changes is
that the social space that one thought
was occupied by civil society is now
filled by government the welfare
programs are crowding out the social
networks that existed for decades in our
civil society and what this is done is
transformed the relationship between
state and society I call it reversing
the polarity of state and society what I
mean is this at times in the history of
the earth you know the magnetic fields
of the two poles were the same direction
and other times they went in the
opposite direction in other words they
propose that they reverse their polarity
for much of American history the poles
of government and civil society worked
together pulling in the same direction
today they are reversed and they are
working against each other and they are
pulling in different directions in
lower-income neighborhoods for example
because the welfare state has replaced
most of the institutions of civil
society the bonds of trust of a welfare
recipient is largely vertical in other
words its upward to the government and
not as they once were largely horizontal
across society where they had to depend
on their family on the church they had
depend on their neighbors they had to
depend on other people to help get them
through crisis they didn't even have the
opportunity or the luxury I think that
somebody in Washington was going to
solve these problems for them so they
devised ways in civil societies create
mutual Assurance associations voluntary
associations it was absolutely richly
and diverse and very quite successful
not only in keeping the the families and
the social units together but also in
making the neighborhood safe and making
them successful so at the same time that
this relationship has changed between
the upward to government in other words
the bonds of trust are now up or the
government the same time mistrust which
used to exist largely between an
individual and government in other words
individuals didn't trust government
much that has been reversed that's why I
call it polarity reversed polarity and
now it exists this mistrust largely
exists horizontally across society
itself new groups and classes that
people compete with one another for
government benefits this not only
heightens their sense of group identity
but puts them at political laws with one
another sometimes entrenching social
conflict but certainly making each of
these groups political competitors
trying to buy for a some kind of favor
from the government there was another
change it occurred as was all of this
the very idea in practice of virtue
changed historically for most of
American history had been considered a
private matter but a private matter with
largely public consequences in other
words it had been mainly about how one
measured up individually as a good or a
bad person and that was considered to be
a prerequisite of freedom between short
enjoy the luxury of freedom now what we
call sometimes it's called political
correctness I don't particularly like
that term but now the idea of virtue has
been transformed into largely where you
stand ideologically where you where you
stand ideologically that defines you as
a person where you are politically
largely that's how Americans think of it
by this I mean that our civic mindedness
is not defined by personally what we do
for society through your charity or
volunteerism but where we stand on a
political issue but when i say ideology
usually means what government is
expected to do for the social issue that
we care about not what we are personally
expected to do the trend is therefore to
create a state endorsed ideology backed
up by in some cases even legally
enforceable norms but more importantly
by socially enforceable norms the old
finger wagging pastor of the 19th
century has been replaced by the
sneering liberal who thinks
opposition to Obamacare must be caused
by de facto razon racism or even a
mental deficiency in other words we
don't want to talk about the essence of
the matter we just want to go to your
motives and where you stand
ideologically and once I know that I
know where you are as a person that
ladies and gentlemen is new at least new
in the sense since the last 50 years
it's not new but it was not around as
heavily as it is today prior to the
1960s I put the the matter this way in
the book i'm just going to quote it
here's a quote the fairly wide radius of
trust that once eased the mutualism of
american civil society in other words
its ability to cooperate is now much
much smaller that radius of trust is
smaller people distrust one another more
not only because they live in different
neighborhoods and they have different
cultures but because they have different
ideas about what civic virtue is and
that's civic virtue as i said is largely
these days defined by where you stand
ideologically but ultimately and this is
the main point of trying to make is that
in this ideological equation it's still
all about what government should or
should not do and that's my opinion the
trap it's I'm a conservative so it's a
government shouldn't do something he's a
liberal the government should do
something and that's where the debate is
and we can't some get out of that trap
by asking sort of other questions about
whether or not a program works or
whether it's appropriate is this what
you expect the government to do maybe we
should be doing something in civil
society differently these questions
don't get asked because we're so
preoccupied by these ideological debates
now let me switch gears here a little
bit there is a
all this is discussed in the book one
way or the other but one of the results
of this change this transformation I'm
talking about is that it has changed the
narrative of what made America a great
country and there are many people in and
the not only the progressive tradition
but in the remnants of the new left
tradition these traditions i just talked
about who believe that the views that i
hold our quote reactionary were hostile
to change their forward enemies of the
future and they believe that all i'm
really trying to do is turn back the
clock I'm quoting here some of the
tweets that my books cotton make war on
the modern world I want to turn America
back to the 19th century to which I
tweeted I seem to think that socialism
was in fitted in the 19th century too
but you know who's going to quibble so
here's what I obviously don't accept
that and explain why what we call
traditional met what I call traditional
American values I'd spent some time
talking about them here believe in
personal responsibility individual
initiative lemon to govern all these
ideas there they are the most modern of
values you can imagine that not only
help make America a modern nation they
revolutionized the entire globe they
made the entire world modern when Edison
invented the electric light and when
Wright brothers flew the first airplane
America was still a country of
traditional values as I described them
here the same was true even in the 50s
when America was undoubtedly still was
at that time the biggest and most
successful country in the history of
mankind but at the same time this was
happening all the traits of modernism is
desire for expanding the frontiers of
freedom it's love of experimentation I
mean after all how do you think these
bicycle makers created the the airplane
there were great experimenters and that
kind of thing was encouraged by this
culture of traditional values at the
time because it was all about individual
initiative
open-mindedness love of freedom yes
they're still existed racism yes they're
still existed segregation and I have a
section in the book where I meet that
head-on I don't want to get off on that
right now but that was part of
fulfilling the original promise of the
American dream that took time but
eventually was fulfilled now problem was
is that the new left that I talked about
completely transformed and changed the
definition of what modernism is to them
is all about Darwin Marx and Freud those
are the three gods of modernism mostly
from the European new left it wasn't
locked Jefferson and Madison it was
Darwin Marx and Freud now here's the
problem i believe and I'd not be curious
if anybody here agrees with me I believe
it was a liberal capitalism and its
creation of wealth and it's providing
freedom for the individual that created
the modern world it was not socialism
God knows it wasn't communism and I
don't even think it was the European
model of social democracy the second
point is that the ideas the values of
the counterculture that i have discussed
here represent more of a rejection of
the Enlightenment than its fulfillment
they can be traced back to the thinking
of jean-jacques Rousseau and his ideas
of sentiment and the collective both of
which were deliberate rejections of the
ideas of lock and the English and
Scottish enlightenment so over time
these ideas may their way mainly through
German idealism not only into Marxism
and the totalitarian ideologies of the
20th century but also this is important
into the romantic conceptions of
nonconformity and Expressionism that
define the counterculture of the 60s now
in what in hindsight what seems to
really terrify or so Marx and others was
the sort of wild openness of the Rising
capital
an industrial world they seem more
comfortable with the old ideals of
communalism which existed in the
pre-capitalist and the pre-industrial
world their worldviews and their values
actually had had actually throwbacks to
the corporate corporatist closed world
of medieval times when the individual is
worth was defined by his membership in
the community the Germans have a word
for this anybody know German
gemeinschaft as opposed to gesellschaft
divine shop was the communal
pre-industrial community where everybody
lived in their own orders and the
gesellschaft was the Society of
businessmen and tradesmen selling the
individual this was a [ __ ] to these
people they were romanticizing the past
and saw bourgeois revolution or the
industrialization or capitalism is
tearing this world down so from this
perspective living in America here in
2013 and also frankly around the world
it was capitalism in the boudoir
revolution not the cultural proletariat
one that made the modern age it wasn't
marks now I've taken some pains to go
through this because I'm not trying to
make some intellectual debating point
I'm making the point because it goes to
the heart of the claim that
conservatives are anti-modern that I'm
anti-modern that I only want to
resurrect a dead past and I have nothing
to say about the future now if what is a
is true about this intellectual history
that I'm laying out it's not the
Conservatives but the countercultural
liberals that are actually the one that
have the trouble with the modern world
which is why they are constantly trying
to go to the government to try to
control it and at the expense of
individual freedom because that
individual freedom is a defense to the
communal values that existed prior to
the rise of the Bush wah
Lucien there's a theory is developed
here by the historian jacques barzun
that applies here and thus this now and
end on this point here he talks about
the great divide in American liberalism
he claims that liberalism of the old
bourgeois classic liberal variety was
once a philosophy dedicated to providing
more freedom for ever greater number of
people but he says no more instead he
has become its opposite today it's
mainly about denying people freedom
supposedly in the interests of society
you see it every time someone tries to
stifle speech in the name of tolerance
or forces you onto a health care plan
you don't want in the name of choice the
words and the ideas have become the
opposite of their meeting which is why a
lot of times today people don't call it
liberalism at all they call it illiberal
ism now this is a lot to lot to digest
and I spent some time I what I did was
for this audience I picked one part of
the book this cultural history and I
dived into a deeper I'm not done this
yet before because this is a very
intelligent audience and I feel I would
not worry too much if I did this but
there is there is the reason why I'm
focusing on this is because I think that
we have to understand that some of the
problems that we're facing today and the
difficulties of solving them a cultural
and we require a cultural answer which
is not political necessarily it's not
politicians I'm not going to solve this
it's going to be a way for younger
generations or future generations of
America to figure out how to interpret
in their own way for their own purposes
what the what works in American history
what that historical DNA is and apply it
to the problems of tomorrow in the way
that works for the society and for this
culture and for this country
and if you can't figure that out then
you could march through the institutions
like my baby boomer friends did in the
60s so 50 years from now you know maybe
you can control the country like they do
now but they did it not through I did it
through some organization but it was
mainly for them an intellectual and a
cultural challenge they were interested
in the arts they were interested in
experimentation they were experienced in
literature they were interested in
culture for its own sake and that is
what made it authentic and that's what
made it successful and they did their
homework and so if this is ever going to
be turned around it's not going to be
returned around by political manifestos
it's going to be turned around by
probably realizing that the course that
we're on right now is not working very
well and there's something inherently
wrong with it and therefore let's try
something new and then we try something
new we try to learn eluded by history
and you figure out well that worked
really well why didn't it work what I
work because of this went together and
it just kind of worked well you know it
was and it's not just about the past
it's about the confluence of
characteristics that work and it worked
for a certain kind of people because is
even though we've changed a lot we still
are Americans and we still come from our
past and we still have in our DNA and
our memory who we were and where we came
from and that's not that's not entirely
lost there's still millions of Americans
who believe in it not only subliminally
but even overtly and and so that's why I
decided to write the book and that's why
I'm here talking to you tonight so thank